[Music]  welcome to Weekend Update I'm Michael  che I'm Colin Jess  not only do Michael che and Colin Jost  work together on SNL they're also pretty  good pals in real life which che proved  when he sent a party clown to Jos  intimate birthday dinner  check out the screen shot che posted to  his Instagram story texting with Colin  right after the clown paid him a visit  the birthday boy of course wearing his  balloon crown sitting next to girlfriend  Scarlett Johansson who clearly loved it  Jose too turned 36 on Friday has a lot  to celebrate  co-host of Weekend Update a head writer  on SNL and a very happy love life why is  she the one for you miss Scarlett  Johansson she's you know she's pretty  cool it's hard to have a lot of  complaints she's pretty awesome  [Music]